hi um okay sorry I'm still overwhelmed
from this honor I want to thank the
Academy from the bottom of my heart for
giving my film this incredible
acknowledgement and this wonderful award
I had the best week this week and I
think the golden moment was when I met
an actor or a veteran el acto just was
in a committee and it was quoting my
film so this is one of the best moments
in my life I want to thank tel aviv
university for believing in supporting
this film especially your own blog the
head of the department i want to thank
the cast of this film first of all the
film two leading actors really amzil and
ill and Al thank you for your amazing
performance and your kindness they are
both quite known in Israel I mean there
are superstars in Israel and your
passion in your work was truly
inspirational I want to thank the
incredible crew member I will just name
a few because of the time Daniel Miller
the deeply I assume the editor Daniels
around the production designer and has a
higher our line producer and I also want
to thank Ruth thinking that my assistant
director who is here and will tell him
ultimately my my producer so thank you I
want to thank my friends and family my
mom and dad weld me so much with this
movie my aunt who persuaded me to go
back to school I want to thank mostly
more My partner was so dedicated to this
film as if it as if it was their own so
Moy I share this with you thank you very
much
you